This is back to do you know
yourself or do you aspire to be
something you might
actually not be.
This is the toughest
question of it all my man.
I mean, if you want to be
respected and and really known--
- [Man] Show up.
- show the fuck up.
I don't know how much into my
content you are but I always
say nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
It's just real.
Do you know how insane DailyVee
and the Snapchat stories has
been to everybody?
They didn't realize how
hard I was going at it.
You can't believe how many, you
can't believe how many people,
you know how many fuckin'
people used to say the word luck.
That word luck has
gone right back.
Nobody has the audacity say that
to my face now and I love it.